Чи зможе Україна мати сильний флот в Азовському морі?
Ми говоримо про це з командувачем ВМС України,
адміралом Ігорем Воронченком.
Доброго дня, пане адмірале.
Дякую, що знайшли час для цього інтерв’ю.
Що Ви особисто відчували, коли ви бачили,
як атакували українські кораблі?
Що Ви особисто відчуваєте, коли бачите, коли вони сидять в полоні?
Я особисто призначав цих командирів кораблів,
і знаю всі екіпажі, на що вони спроможні.
В 2014 році я деякий  час перебував в полоні в Севастополі.
І, як ніхто, відчуваю те, через що вони зараз проходять,
через застінки цих  буцигарень в Росії…
Ми вже не розраховуємо на те, що суд РФ
ухвалить правильне правове рішення
стосовно наших військовополонених.
Вся світова спільнота повинна все ж розуміти,
тільки спільними зусиллями ми зможемо створити передумови
для того, щоб президент РФ прийняв позитивне рішення
щодо визволення наших військовополонених.
Тому що це безперечно…
Одна людина керує державою.
І ніхто в це управління не втручається.
Усе залежить тільки від президента РФ.
Чи володієте Ви 100%-ю інформацією з приводу зброї,
яку застосували проти українських моряків.
Була застосовна артилерійська зброя ПСКР "Ізумруд",
а це шестиствольні 30-тиметрові гармати.
Є інформація, що була застосована зброя з літака і вертольотів.
Існують дуже великі суперечності стосовно
розміру цих вхідних отворів на "Бердянську".
Що це все ж таки було?
Або черга з АК-630 або пуск
однієї некерованої ракети з вертольоту.
Коли катер буде в наших руках, коли ми його заберемо,
тільки тоді отримаємо справді експертний висновок.
Захоплені екіпажі просили про допомогу по радіозв’язку.
В Україні існують ресурси для таких ситуацій?
Відповідний набір сил і засобів у нас є.
Але ж вони виконували завдання в складі тактичної групи.
це був мирний прохід.
На борту катерів перебували курсанти-стажери.
Ми не враховували,  що Росія так жорстоко і так
агресивно буде поводитися стосовно наших катерів.
Багато говорять по те, чому кораблі не відкрили вогонь у відповідь?
Чи передбачено в таких ситуаціях відкривати вогонь?
Якщо проти тебе два гелікоптери сучасних,
два штурмовики, два винищувачі Су-30 і одинадцять кораблів і катерів,
то, я вважаю, що командири (українських) кораблів ухвалили правильне рішення.
І він, - я маю на увазі командира катеру "Бердянськ" Романа Мокряка, -
ще раз підтвердив, що, мовляв, я здійснюю мирний прохід,
я зброю не наводжу на жодний корабель,
артустановки не обертаю.
Росіяни усвідомили, що він їм нічого не спричиняє.
Навіщо було відкривати вогонь по наших катерах
в нейтральних водах, в відкритому Чорному морі?
Україна хоче створити москітний флот. Який план?
Чи є в Вас бачення, яким він має бути?
Ми повинні враховувати фактор ресурсу і фактор часу.
Скажу  відверто: поки що крім москітного флоту,
в нас немає альтернативи.
"Москіти" будуються швидко, не потребують великого ресурсу.
Але вони маневрені, швидкі та спроможні завдавати
відповідних уражень корабельним угрупованням.
Я так розумію,що Україні потрібно не менше ста мільйонів доларів,
десь п’ятдесят катерів, кораблів.
Питання в тому, хто вироблятиме для них озброєння?
Чи є такі ресурси в Україні?
Візьмемо, наприклад , той же малий броньований катер.
Це наш вітчизняний проект, він побудований на вітчизняному підприємстві.
Стосовно озброєння - все вітчизняне;
а зв’язок, навігація та силові установки - закордонні.
Зараз другий проект "Кентавр", з ним практично те ж саме.
В нас вже відпрацьований проект ракетного катеру.
Є варіанти нашого ракетного озброєння і є варіанти іноземного ракетного озброєння.
Ми вже маємо позитивні відгуки для того, щоб усе це поставити на озброєння.
Зрозуміло, що Ви все про флот не скажете.
Але хоч б скажіть, коли Україна отримає патрульні катери США Island?
В липні вони повинні бути у нас, до кінця липня.
Екіпажі готуються, порядок доукомплектації цих кораблів узгоджений.
Узгоджений і порядок спільної підготовки вже там, на базі в Балтиморі.
Скореговані вже і останні заходи , яких ми повинні вжити,
щоб вони якомога швидше прибули в Україну.
Москітний флот може зробити судноплавство безпечним?
Це буде реально сильний флот, котрий потрібен Україні?
Це перший етап задля заборони або обмеження
дій противника на морі, в прибережній зоні.
Щодо подальших дій знадобляться кораблі ,більшої потужності .
В Азовському морі тим складом катерів, які ми плануємо,
я вважаю, можна гарантувати безпеку виробничої діяльності та безпеку судноплавства.
Україна створює нову базу ВМС в Азовському морі.
Але прохід через Керченську протоку проблематичний доволі.
Як існувати цьому флоту без підтримки з Чорного моря?
По-перше, цей міст був незаконно побудований.
По-друге…я в Керчі прослужив 7 років.
І бачив різні плани побудови цього мосту, вони висіли в мера в кабінеті.
Росія , на жаль, обрала найгірший варіант будівництва цього мосту.
Зараз взагалі створена ситуація, коли от це горличко,
дифузор під аркою, течія посилилась, відбувається зсув ґрунту...
Вагалі Керченська протока не дуже сейсмічностійкий район.
Не будемо забігати вперед. Побачимо, як взагалі далі
розвиватиметься ця ситуація, що далі буде з цим мостом .
Без втручання з зовнішнього боку.
Навіть, якщо партнери України по НАТО захочуть надати допомогу флоту в Азові,
вони не зможуть пройти через Керченську протоку, тому що
існує договір між Україною та Росією.
Росія не погодить цей прохід. Що робити в цьому випадку?
Ви праві. Це 100%. Згідно з цим договором
Росія не дасть кораблям НАТО зайти туди.
НАТО буде надавати нам підтримку в плані заходу
і проведення спільних навчань в акваторії Чорного моря.
Кожен захід натівського корабля, есмінця США,
викликає в Росії не те щоб занепокоєння, а паніку.
Тому що вони знають, що таке есмінець США,
який несе на борту бойовий ракетний потенціал всього Чорноморського флоту РФ.
Повірте мені, все ж таки всі договори будуть виконані.
Росія піде на те, щоб їх все ж виконувати.
Я сподіваюся, що усі санкції , всі заходи,
які впроваджують ключові гравці світу, G7 ,G20,
щодо Росії , зрештою, зроблять свою справу.
Як Ви оцінюєте актуальне співвідношення сил в Азовському морі?
Зараз, на жаль, (ситуація) не на нашу користь
як щодо кількісного, так і якісного співвідношенню.
Переважна кількість кораблів та катерів Чороморського флоту
та ФСБ перебувають в Азовському морі.
За нашими підрахунками, їх кількість вже перевалила за сотню.
Безпосередньо тих кораблів та катерів, які можуть повно функціонально
виконувати завдання,з російського боку приблизно 36-40 одиниць.
В нас там, на жаль, зараз 2 катери і 2 кораблі.
От, тепер рахуйте, яке може бути співвідношення.
Наразі у ВМС немає окремого бюджету, так?
Але ж, якщо створювати москітний флот, потрібно фінансування. Так?
Не те, що немає, він виділений. І 2017-го року
я підписав перший контракт щодо модернізації нашого фрегату.
І на останній зустрічі міністр оборони заявив, що нам буде наданий великий ресурс.
Я готую пропозиції для того, щоб він був вірно розподілений.
Безперечно, практика країн альянсу показує, що той командувач,
який відповідає за виконання завдань , повинен мати і відповідний бюджет.
І наявність ресурсу - основний фактор успіху.
Як Ви особисто ставитеся до введення моніторингової місії ОБСЄ в Азовському морі?
Я скажу відверто. Я бачив, як працює місія в 2014 році,
бо я за неї відповідав в Луганській області.
Є зафіксовані кадри, їх в youtube можна переглянути.
Так ось, позитивний результат буде лише тоді, коли
буде надана об’єктивна оцінка усім діям з боку РФ.
Допомагали з 18-ти членів тодішньої місії всього 2 представники – Великобританії і Данії.
Інші тільки працювали на Росію. 2 з 18 були росіянами. Яка це об’єктивна оцінка?
Сепаратисти контролюють узбережжя біля Новоазовську.
Чи виникають там конфліктні ситуації?
Самопровоголошена ДНР створила там міфічну флотилію.
Так, вони зібрали рибацькі човни. Десь там 20-25 швидкохідних човнів.
На маріупольському напрямку з їхнього боку стоїть якийсь там 9-й полк морської піхоти.
Вони його ще й назвали цікаво - "Штурмовий полк морської піхоти".
За 10 місяців перебування там цієї бригади морської піхоти,
співвідношення сил на нашу користь.
І за втратами безперечно, ситуація на нашу користь. Прямих зіткнень на морі не було.
Чи є взагалі існує якась комунікація між українським та російським флотом?
Офіцери чкось спілкуються один з одним?
Це питання мені ніхто не ставив. Я очікував…
Це Ви перша, яка поставила це питання.
Яка може бути комунікація після 26 лютого 2014 року?
Яка може бути комунікація з нашими зрадниками, які
залишилися там, які зрадили присязі і своєму народові?
Жодних контактів з Чороморським флотом
ми не підтримуємо і не будемо підтримувати.
Жодні (спільні) міжнародні договори щодо чорноморської безпеки,
це передусім BLACKSEAFOR, ми зараз не підтримуємо.
Це ми заявили і на останній конференції.
В двостороньому порядку діє "Чорноморська гармонія" з Туреччиною. Це і все!
І ми суттєво посилили контакти з нашими
румунськими, болгарськими і грузинськими партнерами. І з Туреччиною теж.
Наскільки реальна ситуація, що Україна втратить контроль над Азовським морем?
Не втратимо контроль.
Однозначну оцінку зараз давати не буду.
Зараз ситуація дуже складна, особливо в Приазов'ї,
особливо в цих ключових точках нашого півдня, нашого Сходу.
Зараз є той стан ЗСУ, який спроможний виконати завдання.
Це не2014рік
Дуже дякую Вам за відповіді, пане адмірале.
Дякую Вам.